b b hey y'all 2024 I am going to be on
tour assuming I don't die in childbirth
I'm going to take a couple months down
to um heal up whatever nightmare happens
when this vampire tears through my body
but I'm going to take some time uh work
on some new material so that June 28th
2024 when I'm in Erie Pennsylvania at
the Warner Theater you're going to see
all new yolks I'm also going to be in
Las Vegas Nevada July 6th 2024 at the
marage
big Big Show and then July 17th 2024
I'll be in Edmonton Alberta Canada at
The Great Outdoors Comedy Festival I'll
be there with the one and only Bert ker
who by the way has him and I have
swapped bodies by the way very rude
Steph toov will also be there it's a
Amazing Outdoor fun show so come get
Lyme disease come get whatever whatever
attacked by a bear while watching um us
do some yucks also I have a new special
out it's
on.tv Whitney free uncensored it's on
only fans TV Don't Panic it's not only
fans the subscription side you're not
going to see any mil porn any Step
Brothers you're not I'm not going to be
performing and then someone knocks on
the door and they're like pizza's here
it's not porn it's their it's their
television side um very wholesome
of.tv Whitney free UNS answered I yell
about trans people for about 20 minutes
check it out can you hear me cuz I don't
have the headphones all right this is
well I'm also three feet away from you
all right I know I always say that when
I'm in a small room in a club I'm like
what if we were just stalking the club
and it's like Jorge I need more red
solos you can't hear me can you hear me
more red solos can you hear me is
basically is this thing on yeah I meant
like do you want headphones we have
somewhere okay I need them I think
they're ridiculous we're not flying a h
you're not a mil all right I'm going to
sit up then you have a fuzz on your hat
though fuzz on your
hat top um uh Pat is s Pat has never
gotten out of his chair to help a guest
for anything Pat wild thank you
Pat um let's go to the van
so I sold my house okay I believe that
the world is weird so I have a by weird
you mean imploding quickly yes so I kept
I have cash in the bank okay and you're
putting cash in banks are you insane
isn't that the weirdest thing that's
going on I I don't love that either did
you put money in crypto or nft I've done
yeah that okay um which is why you to
sell your house
yeah but so I bought a van
because I have like like my buddy he
told me about this company and they do
vans I'll give him a shout out just
Sandy vans in San Diego okay and they
pimp out Sprinter vans sick and so I
said this is what I want I want the
ability to pod I want the ability to
stream I want storage I want a little
bit of area for my gear an RV yeah but
it's a Mercedes yeah here's what's funny
so I took it to funny you should ask
yesterday everyone loves it even like
all the different even John was like wow
this is not bad SE love it this is
bigger than my
apartment so it it's I believe if I'm
going to be on tour I do a lot of stuff
on the road tour and cons and all this
but there is like I'm tired ofly I mean
I'm GNA fly but flying sucks yeah but
there is an underlying motive of also
War of the Worlds I need to be able to
live in this thing at some
point uh I definitely have it stored up
I mean I'm not that person but I think
that I'm becoming that person and is it
more about La wildfires or California
fires or like nuclear war or just the
zombie apocalypse the fires the last I'm
thinking about I didn't think about the
fires until I just walked up your
drive I was
like this
is I mean this is a beautiful purchase
but it's a brave purchase
it's you know what I'm saying where I
live and all the Witchcraft we know that
I do and all my seances and book burning
but look at the 10 they just burnt the
10 down it's concrete yeah but that was
uh arson 100% arson so you know I like a
dork and I do e coin evacuation with
like lfd when there's fires and I feel
like I shouldn't even say this but
someone in lafd told me that most
wildfires in California are arson or
from homeless people's like encampments
and stuff but if they told everyone that
people would just start taking baseball
bats to homeless people and it would be
like a problem so they have to be like
yeah forest fires wildfires like yeah so
I take that
science so I I just feel that you we H I
know that sounds crazy but we have to
kind of have a little bugout vehicle you
know what I got bug out bug out vehicle
and like I'm friends with a lot of
people that we talk about this shit and
friends in Idaho and friends in OC and
Cummins is coming here later today he
lives in Idaho there you go so it's like
I think that you just should have a
little something you know what I don't
have that I go weird I feel like I have
a list of the things I need to have one
of them is a generator yep you got to
get that but I don't know who to call I
don't know solar gener I need to get a
husband or something yeah a so no can I
tell I got a pat a poor Pat he comes
over these days I'm like can you move
this chair can you take this bandaid off
I can't reach it it's I've already
really pushed can you help me with my
bird yeah I'm crowning can you fix this
wait no you you you you need a generator
you need a solar but you know that solar
actually sometimes a scam too there was
this um company in Arizona that had put
all these solar panels on all these
houses and people I mean they're
expensive you know like 50 80 grand or
something and they weren't doing
anything but like how would you really
notice like like you know what I mean so
to me I had to get my electric bill and
really like go through it and then I
have to have another expert cuz when I
bought the house that had solar and make
sure they're actually doing what they're
supposed to be doing yeah cuz what if
your sh just
not soling yeah you got to start with
like two pin you have to like maintain
them and like make sure like have some
meter and read them and stuff well
there's a whole scam too we don't have
to go down there but where you we
apparently there's enough son something
to the point I had a guy on my podcast
there's enough son in Cal in California
to like do the whole nation also yeah
because also by the way if you have
solar panels and this is where things
got Shady because part of the reason I
bought this house is it was solar and
and they were like you'll have to pay no
electric not only that you're going to
make so much that the that California
will have to pay you back but they don't
do that they don't allow you to sell it
as much you could have unlimited amount
of solar power and they won't only let
you sell x amount why because that's how
the system is it's rigged I had a guy on
my pod break it down I can't really do
it but it's like if you had x amount of
gigawatts they only buy x amount from
you cuz a lot of times people go oh I'm
going to put 30 Grand in these solar P
panels and over time I'll actually be
able to make that money back and you can
just like make it a business how else
are you going to make money in
California yes aside from just free
sunlight yeah it ain't at the haha nah
shout out I mean haha Cafe we love you
um okay so you got your bugout vehicle
what's like the number one thing you're
like I'm getting in my van to bug out if
things get weird like what is Def find
weird I mean I look I've been looking at
bunkers I've
been I I could why do you have a bug out
anyway I have a
Subterranean
polar aquatic
bunker don't worry it has a comedy club
in
it it's got an open mic night we'll be
fine Open Mic here's what I would
say um
you what can I tell you it's weird
things are weird very and so this next
election is things are going to get very
okay uh what election yeah exactly
seriously now I can tell you that you're
a smart person okay you went to pen okay
my brother and sister went to I'm sorry
let me stop you smart people don't go to
Ivy League schools stupid people now go
to Ivy League schools well now when you
went now good point that's a good point
at the time it meant something stupid
people go now it's a complete freaking
waste of money yes I think that college
especially ones like that yeah and I had
to pay off my loans for I mean I
literally just paid off my loans to a
bunch of now to a to an ively school
that like gets saudy money I'm gonna get
in trouble I can't go on this rant no
didn't you see there was this um I think
bar Weiss did this whole thing about how
are you an end how these know how these
um ively schools were taking Saudi money
I mean half of them took EP money but
Penn didn't wow I think college is kind
of a Eugenics program at this point it's
like you meet your future husband your
future wife your future business partner
like all these Tech dorks like they met
each other at Harvard or Yale and then
they take over the world it's more about
getting together as opposed to what are
you learning yeah exactly exactly I just
think that my vehicle has the solar it's
got gas has enough electric I've got
food in there I've got the ability to
broadcast I've got Sky uh link which I
think is very starlink this sounds like
someone that just like wants to be that
lives with his girlfriend and every now
and then just needs a break I have a man
cave
but no and I just think that it's like I
don't know power's been going in and out
of the city um here's the main thing do
how much you g to judge and you do have
starlink I have starlink yeah 100% good
uh a gigs my I hate the way my agent
routes gig so I want to route my from
here to Diego to Vegas to Arizona to so
I could probably do a little run like
that nice um the thing is is that do you
just drive in the streets and you just
see kind of lowkey zombies not even
lowkey like forget the drugs okay you
see the encampments which you know it's
sad but like I do in my joke it is sad
but not every one of those people have
fallen on Hard Times some of them have
fallen on a needle okay a lot by the way
a lot of them in in Los Angeles half the
homeless en Camp there's ring lights
yeah I mean they're not trying to ascend
their circumstances they are resigned to
their camping the weather is good enough
to be able to actually do this that was
ivy league right there Ascend your
circumstances I didn't learn that at
Community College this is I mean there's
also they're also talented I mean
there's you can go down to Venice and
there's homeless people roller skating
with machetes they will just come by and
slice a bitch I mean they will kill you
in the most elegant way possible the
just the slice capades don't like they
they come at you which the slice caade
stop it you know what's kind of I've
heard this that usually Scientology
cleans up the homeless problem in
California and a lot of places in
America Scientology and they won't even
pick them up well here's what it is
though I saw this cute like 21y old girl
bare foot not that dirty in front of
Gelson's Beachwood the other day it was
like 6:50 in the morning uhuh and she
was like that was shyan Woodley yeah so
and I'm like this chick had no idea
about the traffic I know people say it's
drugs she seemed cognizant I mean she
was literally tuned into a different
frequency and I'm seeing younger
different types of people all
ethnicities all I'm sorry all
ethnicities and I'm like this is you
know this is all encompassing here and
people just seem off this is a dumb
story but I'm going to tell you quickly
two weeks ago Alan Ruck I'm glad he's
won ful and great from succession
amazing actor drove into raf's okay
which is right on the corner of
Hollywood and Le right I don't know I
don't know exactly what happened I think
everyone's okay last night I wanted to
eat Italian food I haven't had by the
way the fact that Allan Ruckers said his
predat of succession is very offensive
well he said so many things but that's
his
most I did a movie with alen he's
amazing I'm just saying that's his most
current yes I'm joking he's so long
story boring is I go I haven't been to
this place in a while I want to go to
Jones I'm going to go to Jones on on on
fucking Santa Monica have a little pasta
and clams and I'm like it's too far so I
ended up having sushi on my way to
driving there Jones somebody runs into
Jones and drives into Jones through the
dining
room so what am I trying to tell you
there's cars driving in the buildings
now you're gonna say that's two times
Jamie calm down people that's a crazy
telling you 5G there's some popping off
cat is lowkey with me and I'm going to
convert you I no I'm wait you're trying
to convert me I think you're delusional
I think it's so much worse than you
think it is oh I think it's way worse
I'm seeing how we're just dipping our
toes in I Joe Rogan and said there's
fentanyl in the water in
California people are like what the no
because I had this this um so start with
the animals the animals will always tell
you everything okay this is why I'm a
animal person what's your dog telling
you um my dog is obsessed with you big
fan of Malibu's Most Wanted mono's Most
Wanted over here my dog is obsessed with
him she they know they know who to
follow in a crisis too she's just like
this guy's got a
I'm but so okay so I had this issue in
my yard where I was fostering this puppy
so I had to go out and let the puppy pee
in the middle of the night I'm like
groggy walk outside uh this raccoon runs
up my leg like a baby raccoon runs up my
leg EG thinks it's a
tree very insulting but let's get past
that um and I probably need to use more
lotion I don't know why the the raccoon
conflated my leg with a tree different
conversation for a different day and the
the next day I ended up having to go get
a rabies um M to Global antibodies who
cares but the next day I see the raccoon
hanging the mom the adult bit by a
raccoon didn't get bit but I did have
like a cut on my leg or something so I
ended up just going to get the mon curl
antibiotic is just because like I had a
cut whatever and so um I basically call
animal control because it's not acting
feral like I'm poking at it and it's
kind of just tired it's it's you're
poking at the raccoon with a broom yeah
it's mining its own business no but I
feel like you're an animal Karen get
come on get down it's not your natural
habitat come here you're you're a
canimal look over here I need my content
get in there
I mean you go to the woods and disturb a
raccoon no so but raccoons they should
run away from you they should they
should run away so it's sick it's got
rabies it's got something and you are
supposed to report that because then if
a coyote eats it and then the coyot and
whatever and rabies can spread so you're
supposed to call Animal Control I call
animal control and I only in California
do you call animal control and I was
like uh there's a raccoon acting very
weird in this tree and she goes yeah
that's its home I said that's what I I
was like no this is my home bitch and I
was like no no it's acting very bizarre
like it's lethargic it's not moving it
probably has rabies like someone needs
to come remove this raccoon and she goes
well the thing is that right now A lot
of people are testing their cocaine for
fanol and if it tests positive they
flush it down the toilet so there's been
a lot of fentanyl in the water and the
coyotes and the raccoons are acting very
strange wow so not only do we have
fluoride in our water which is already
giving us who knows what kind of
neurological Dam
from the fact that if we're drinking tap
water we already have fluoride in it and
then who knows what's going on from
everybody flushing their cocaine wow I
mean I I never thought I'd complain
about less people doing cocaine but I
guess now that they're testing for
fentanyl it's getting flushed also this
is a hot take very hot take is someone
who was pretty addicted to weed in
January December January and had to
fully stop just two two months you were
a full-on addict for 2 months wait what
hold on very efficient I get in and I
get out someone is a full-blown addict
for 60 days let me tell you some stuff
what well well I definitely had smoked
weed before but that's when it started
being like oh this is a little out of
hand that's when I started like you know
looking for Shelly
miscavage wow you know what I mean you
really gone down I'm proud of you but
what I'll say is that I think I'm not
saying weed shouldn't be legal it's just
so so strong everyone say so strong now
is that it so strong now because it's
government mandated I also I think there
just need to be laws within it like
there should be a law that nothing's
called like the Rice Krispy treat strain
yeah or the you know what I mean the
rocky road ice cream stream cuz that
that's just what they're doing they're
getting you they make think it's a
dessert that's it makes it just seem a
little more benign than it is or
something I don't know like or there's
something about it so I think a lot of
people I mean I didn't drive into Jones
um but I think a lot of people are doing
Edibles like all day every day and a lot
of people are micro doing mushrooms
that's another thing everyone's off
everyone's they're on
ssris they're on pills they're on no
there's an Aderall shortage in America
yeah there's an Aderall shortage on huge
Aderall problem what I I don't ad all I
have a a director friend and she she has
a whole thing about it yeah can't and
now I know this is a lie
and she works at the clinic and she says
Aderall is a major Addiction in
Hollywood and it's actual addiction no
huge and she's like and it's meth yeah
it's meth and she goes into it and how
you can't go off of it right away and
all of this stuff and people are Zola
whatever Zola everyone's medicated
everyone's medicated and so they're all
twisted up are you on nothing I'm on
nothing I'm on nothing now I'm on I I'm
not saying I'm sober but I haven't drank
in 5 years and that not because I'm
sober just because I started getting
Puff
and you drink a glass of everything was
like Italian uh wine Sushi Saki great
beer Belgian with Burger so food and
beer it was just or rat party you know
boom and then I was like fat like puffy
face and getting up out of bed just two
glasses of wine F like someone punched
me in the face I think the thing is
about wine it's the is it the phalates
is that what it's called Pat like you
can get wine that's organic red wine
that doesn't have the phades that's
supposed to be better you know have you
ever done lymphatic drainage it's like a
brush dry brush I've tried that sure
that helps with the puffiness too I love
that I'm like let me help you drink
again no but I think like I would do it
again I just like been so busy and like
it's good to be focused and I actually
kind of the world's so crazy it's kind
of I'm high this room I'm high it is
true it is true now that I'm on nothing
everyone's like dude you seem like
you're on ader I'm like no I'm actually
this is my personality unfortunately but
I think also something that happens when
you stop doing everything like even
being on birth control I felt like such
a zombie all the time you know birth
control is intense dude it's a weird
time to like if it works for you great I
did it for 20 years like for a Litany of
reasons I'm als you know the only thing
more stressful than being on birth
control all that time probably would be
having a kid before I was ready so
whatever but the point is like you know
I think that now that I'm off everything
I'm so like hyper tuned to people and
like and and you realize like like so
many people are on so many things so
you're also seeing and feeling like a
lot of yeah you probably never noticed
before well we're already going to be
checked in right because we're actors
Comedians and also therapists and so the
energy exchange is so intense that it's
like after I'm done in shows and stuff
or doing I just like to vegetate but
don't you feel like it's like I'm I'm
saying this is like a like not it is
what it is when you're like everyone's
on drugs and like it does feel like that
but it's also like I'm feeling a lot of
people are in a lot of pain people are
scared and people have nothing to lose
and like you know you drive around and
like I went to across from the Improv A
friend of mine has a hair salon and I
went over and um and this uh you know
they've dealt with because I sometimes
bring my dog there and I'm like you can
have my dog for the day cuz like
homeless people will just come in and
just be wild and sometimes they'll
they'll come in to work and they'll be a
homeless
like people that have slept in and broke
inside you know like if you're a small
business like you really have to protect
yourself and um and so as we were
leaving it was like 7 o'clock at night
this homeless dude or like this street
per guy like here's the thing about it
you know like if you listen to Rogan or
these high performers you were trying to
be more politically correct some Street
dude some trash man verman what are we
calling now well someone try to be like
we call them unhoused I'm like what the
unhoused unhoused like most people live
in apartments what are you talking about
everyone's on house no one can buy a
fucking house anymore yeah um non-public
toilet users and not even toilets they
now and because oh yeah yeah and I have
a joke about it in the 90s they would go
behind the building now they're just
right in front of you different type of
homeless well because also it's like you
list to like Andrew huberman and these
like high performers like Peter AA and
Joe Rogan and literally the advice is be
in the Sun for two hours a day that's
superpowers you walk Barefoot in the
grass y you get charged the ions you're
grounding like they're high performing
fast fasting fasting big yeah so they're
healthier than any of us you know so
this guy walks up he's barefooted he's
he had like like um hot like like uh
like machinist body like he was in great
shape because you know in La there's
outdoor exercise gyms they yeah they do
Street
workout so y'all know I'm pregnant
I'm horny and I'm not going to take it
anymore I'd just like to thank God for
funlove.com share the love make fun love
today this holiday season whether you're
shopping for someone naughty someone
nice preferably naughty in the sheets
and nice in the streets as they say
visit funlove.com to find the best gifts
ever for your partner your lover or your
friends or even yourself funlove.com is
a leading online retailer of sensual
health and wellness products offering
the widest selection of premiere brands
of toys lingerie and accessories they
make a perfect stocking stuffer if you
know what I mean by that hey so go
indulge and find Unforgettable presents
and gifts for people on your list at
funlove.com Discover the Allure of
intrigued intimate products a collection
of Premier his hers and couples toys
exclusively available at funlove.com
browse a wide variety of vibrators beads
bullets rabbits G-spot toys dildos
massagers body w bonds and bondage kits
marriage Rescuers relationship fixers
fight Enders boredom eradicators sanity
restorers weapons to fight off texting
an X just because your hormones are
tricking you into thinking that's a good
idea you name it they've got it and find
whatever tickles your fancy and my
crevice is as fancy as they get Intrigue
intimate products are only available at
funlove.com for a limited time receive
50 that's 50% off fun love
exclusive Intrigue collection when you
enter code good for you@ funlove.com
again enter code good for you to receive
50% off Intrigue at funlove.com look at
this ball gag I'm definitely bring this
bringing this to my birth don't you
think yeah you'll need it you'll need
it I'm bringing this to my birth I'm
bringing this and then also look these
handcuffs he handcuff me to the bed like
handmaid's tail only consensual and
fun I'll be like guys and then we'll
live stream it on only fans I'm an
entrepreneur guys look y'all I'm going
to give it to you straight being
pregnant is not as fun as getting
pregnant I'm about to find out what
giving birth feels like but honestly the
only thing that I think would be more
painful than giving birth is starting a
successful company I do not get it I
Stan you cat Schneider rituals founder
who started ritual because she couldn't
find a prenatal that she could trust
like you think it's hard to find a male
an trust try finding a prenatal there's
some very shady prenatal out there some
very spooky packaging the ones that just
look like pills but they kind of smell
like a pet shop you open it and it's
just anium of like musty sadness it's
like this cannot be good for my baby's
brain you know I've already used ritual
for years the omegas which is probably a
big part of why I got healthy enough in
the first place to even conceive a human
so it made sense once I started 3D
printing one that I used ritual prenatal
rituals prenatal vitamin is vegan
bioavailable and clinically studied key
nutrients are perfect for before and
during pregnancy no catch high quality
formulation with nature identical
choline and clinically studied
methylated folate by the way Gary Brea
was just talking about this on Rogan
that a lot of the stuff that we're
taking we can't even methylate so you
have to get it pre-methylated I'm just
saying don't take it from me take it
from a smart man and then you'll believe
me to support baby's neural tube
development before and during pregnancy
neural tube I don't know exactly what it
does but it sounds really important and
I don't want my baby's neural tube to be
tied even though I'm tying mine after
after this guy comes out 350 milligrams
a vegan and sustainably sourced omega-3
DHA to support baby's brain development
during pregnancy so your baby isn't a
stupid idiot
there
their their Citrus or mint essenced
capsules are designed to be gentle on
the stomach so you can take them when
you want with or without food why settle
for a multivitamin you're not 100% sure
about ritual was literally built on
trust so you know it's the real deal
ritual is offering my listeners 30% off
during your first month visit ritual.com
Whitney to start ritual or add essential
for women pre-natal to your subscription
Tada don't be a silly
goose
I've been listening to your podcast I
don't think I knew you were just
slinging The Bravery grenades like this
are they bravery gra you're like on
another level really yeah I'm like
obsessed with you like your podcast
which I love that it's called hate to
break it to what a great title oh thank
you what am I doing I just love that
you're going I just feel like sometimes
I'm such a coward but other times I feel
like I'm the only person who's like
we're all just cool that Hollywood was
built on the back of a 5-year-old child
named Shirley Temple we're just fine
with This brilliant take 100% fine with
this 100% true 100% true you've looked
at her interviews with Larry King right
dude I the whole thing I think about it
three times a day it drives me nuts and
the sound of Freedom thing you've been
very outspoken on and I did have to take
down a clip because I was factiously
just kind of going like yes of course
this you know and forget about the the
guy that um made that sound of Freedom
was based on Tim Ballard I guess he had
some allegations and you know yeah they
didn't seem that bad I don't know I just
asking two girls to shower if you're
getting kids out of being trafficked
feels like he earned it
yeah I mean maybe he's trying to save
water the guy's the guy's a hero yeah
he's also sa he's also eco-friendly he
was doing climate change that's so funny
I mean I don't know they were in Tha
land there's not a ton of water yeah
yeah but I don't even know his charges
but wait see here's the thing this is
what okay you got me going let me stay
focused here okay sorry so sound of
Freedom child trafficking movie you were
just very outspoken about why it wasn't
distributed by Major distributors in
Hollywood because it's complet okay
here's what it is it's the whole game is
rigged it's complete bull here's a movie
was made for I think $18 million
completely independent about the most
the most heinous subject that you can
think of right like there's a lot of
rabbit holes we can go down I'm not
going to go down too deep but let's just
say human trafficking top three and
worst in the planet let's just go
trafficking of children I think it's
safe to say harming children's number
one yes protecting children should be
the number one thing theet Holocaust and
but the children are yes all of it just
the most innocent thing on the planet
Planet should be protected that's right
and so what is Hollywood it's a system
to make something that makes a lot of
noise okay so they make what should it
do it Praises art so here's a guy that
takes a horrific subject yep makes it a
movie gets
no backing not only no mainstream press
but they maligned them but we know why
which you made a good point I think well
this was my my guess
is because he played Jesus in a movie so
what no I agree with you I think this is
their and I'm not going the direction
and Jews run Hollywood it's more sorry I
was trying to Google something and now
my things are coming off uh my
notifications are dinging um I think
that people in Hollywood I'm just I'm
supporting your point but I think that
people in Hollywood and the like extreme
left in general assumes anything that's
Christian is right-wing and they assume
anything that's right I I I WR I agree
with you I saw your post and I thought
it was great you talked about this and
then anything that's right-wing they
assume is like Q andon they can't you
know what I'm saying come on man let me
so it's so crazy so how this is what
makes me crazy I'm not saying it's it's
correct I'm saying I think that's how
they think and yeah you're right and
that's what I'm saying come on man to
them like so you got this they make it
independently they have no support
literally they have to go on like Rumble
to promote the not even YouTube which by
the way the thing that the thing that
actually is the most heartwarming about
the whole thing when you stop thinking
about the Sinister Hollywood um reaction
is that word of mouth was so strong
which means that people care like people
care about this issue yeah and it it was
like oh my God it made so much money
without Hollywood that was the a little
glimmer of hope that I haven't had in a
really long time because if it made a
ton of money with Hollywood you'd be
like oh maybe they just fudged the
numbers or maybe they just like forced
it in theaters or maybe they just paid
for it to be successful but you're like
no this was like a Grassroots thing no
it was totally Grassroots they made it
independently it made almost 200 million
about a terrible subject and so that was
already like Hollywood already did it
dirt the people spoke the movie theaters
were fuck that's all that's all but
don't you think probably the big
Distributors thought oh this isn't going
to well anyway let's just not because if
we distribute it then people are going
to start looking into the skeletons in
our closet wait there's two different
thoughts there I just mean like if if
you like remember there was this that
guy either Hollywood didn't think it was
going to make money or they didn't want
them it's not going to make money anyway
so if we don't help it so why even get
involved because if we take it on and
make it successful people are going to
go wait you're making a movie about
because whenever someone has like a c a
righteous cause if people smell
hypocrisy they start sniffing to the
skeletons in their closet it's like you
know whenever someone gets The Daily
Show people go through the old tweets
remember what happened with Trevor Noah
you know what I mean it's like that guy
is it Eric Schneider that was his name I
don't know why I always use this guy as
an example of when he just out of
nowhere during the Weinstein before
Weinstein was arrested he just did a
press conference in New York for no
reason he was the district attorney
maybe being like I just want to let
everyone know that I think Harvey wi
seems a scumbag and like the next day
like seven hookers were like ah he
choked us out in yeah well you have to
be the virtue signaling you have to
always watch out always have to watch
say that I should have just used that
word it's like white Knights it's like
the man that wears a shirt that says
feminist you're like it's the guy that
says hey he's a scumbag I'll walk you to
your car honey just come down this alley
it's a shortcut yeah so it's like I'm
sure that that these big streamer or not
streamer like big studios would go like
well if we distribute this then
everyone's going to look into the
skeletons in our closet I don't I mean
listen there's a lot of fuck in our
business but I don't think like
Executives thought like that I think
probably the tops have this type of yeah
but what I'm thinking is they didn't
want to promote it because that's
definitely in there but the other thing
what made me so mad is people we know
too they tried to malign it like yo they
brought attention to this subject it
made money and yet you're you don't have
to like it but they actively went
against it well yeah people went against
it and that's like what what was the
logic of it the logic was something like
that it wasn't true yeah he this guy was
an egomaniac and he was going down to
see and not everything is factual okay
so maybe not everything was correct I
don't know enough but he made the movie
and it was about to help people and it
brings awareness to a terrible subject
and people were maligning it and that
really got me nuts to the point I was
drop names so I don't I'm not saying
that's not untrue like I'm sure that guy
is an egomaniac like fine but I don't
care as long as you're saving kids I
don't really care what's the bigger win
here but then why did why was taken done
uh is it because it was done by
Hollywood taken I you know what I don't
know enough about but a lot of people
said that but taken was like the huge
star and it was more like I don't think
people realize it was such a real thing
like it was more like this hardcore
drama and action and it was more like
you know the Liam niss but this was like
based on a real thing and that's yeah
that's I don't know I didn't ever look
at taken and go oh I gotta go stop this
problem a good point but now I did I was
like Jesus Christ do you know that the
Super Bowl is the number one place for
trafficking this is what I've been told
I didn't know this who told you it makes
sense uh multiple people that have you
know I started talking to different like
sound of Freedom like people like just
normal people uh oh we're all
no where do you find sound of Freedom no
they're everywhere I mean just like us
there's people in our community that
like the movie I'm not going to name
names but they're normal people we're
normal here the dark side of the Super
Bowl yeah that was told um most people
don't realize that the Super Bowl has a
dark side is the impetus for what is
commonly known as the largest incident
of human trafficking in the United
States with the influx of several
hundred, tourists most of which are male
large sporting events such as the Super
Bowl become an idea can you guys just
get on only fans already please can you
just pay adults for sex what's the
problem they'll put on a a little mini
skirt yeah they'll suck their thumb like
here's the thing I PE it was the fact
that no one actively supported it it's
when the movie was making money they
were on it it's the same thing they do
when a movie doesn't do well financially
and another movie they don't like kills
it and they prop up the Lesser one
because that's who they want to win and
so they were actively blocking and if
you're saying well why wouldn't
Hollywood want this I do think it's the
the Christian thing I think many things
but let's just remember one thing I have
one word for you
Balenciaga weird okay I actually have
weird okay I let's talk I'm not scared
to say it let's talk about that in a
second because I did have a theory about
that but I will say and this this is
what got me in trouble maybe I said it
too soon well cuz you know it's like
Comics like we our skill is timing right
our skill is timing and you know you
don't want to be too soon you don't want
to be too late you want to be relevant
you know you don't want to be covering
something that people already sick of
talking about or you know or you're
covering something before they've
actually seen it so I think I maybe just
said this on Instagram like too soon
about the sound of Freedom thing because
I hadn't made it clear that obviously
like I'm you know what did you say well
I just was like I do now that we know
that this needs to that we need to draw
awareness this the most important topic
good on the
planet also can we get rid of child
acting like why like within sound of
freedom in the sequel can you guys use
midgets you can't say that word yeah
that's the word that's gonna take you
down all the shit he said the m word not
the NW the N word am I supposed to say
little peeps little the little
pizzles tiny TI cutie P cutie pie follow
away that also is in trouble on that's
also a movie that we that's a
whole Little Cuties was that called
Little Cuties Cutie Pies oh my God wait
I don't think child Listen by the way
you're on the right path with child the
child acting thing but I don't I don't
yes you're on a great but I don't think
every one of them is has nefarious
things but a lot listen talk to some of
my friends who are 40 who are child
actors and they're smoking a cigarette
like this and you drive past Bob's Big
Boy in Burbank like uh can we go eat uh
somewhere else I mean like you know what
I'm saying yeah yeah one of them just
tried to fight me in my friend's hair
salon child actor I'm kidding that no
but I just mean like I I do think you
know within the movie about child sex
trafficking like are we making a child
famous for being sex trafficked in a
movie like how are we cast you know what
I mean it's like I just think
auditioning children in the process of
putting children in movies yeah that's
intense is to I think that's not okay
not into it you know when you send a
meme uh a giy sorry on the iPhone or a
giy youy is that's a gif or is it a gif
a gif I don't know I said it either I
say giy or JY I hate you and so when you
look at these gify like sometimes you go
on there and if you want to put like
dance or something you'll see like a
five-year-old and a tutu listen that's a
whole other and you're like there's lots
of kids in GIFs that are famous that I'm
like even like the girl you just made
the face the girl who's in the back of
the car and she's
like I'm like that's someone's kid you
know it's like a famous GIF of a girl
just like looking like this but she's
like oh yes lots of toddlers in the gift
section that's is it or isn't it but no
that was a double and time you said lots
of toddlers in the gift
section like they could be bought I'm
sorry that was a joke but not it's
fucked up that was like truth with humor
the question is is can children consent
to being famous no as someone that is
about to have a child and would like to
get in an agent
immediately please tell me I'm being
dramatic okay um your baby there's a
high chance that your baby's going to
come out very beautiful you know what
I'm saying I don't know the dad no one
does
but the me especially
but if all it could be one well there's
a couple that visit I'm not allowed to
say that oh Byron Allen please be Byron
Allen
amazing so there's a chance that your
your child will be very beautiful like
the mother now you're in the biz thank
you oh okay well that's just true so
you're in the biz obviously you're not
going to let the child not after this
podcast but but if you were a normal mom
and you didn't have have it and somebody
said oh your baby's would you let the
baby start doing like print modeling and
stuff well here's what's tricky about it
is that you go okay I am able to work a
job where I'm able to pay my bills and
be financially solvent yeah if someone
there's a woman who doesn't and she's
able to
procure funds by putting her kid on
Instagram or whatever and help pay for
that kid's college and make money it's
that's a tougher call for me to do it is
just you you don't need to gross yes you
know but if someone else does it who's
struggling financially that went through
a bad divorce that you know I had
parents that had Strokes without health
insurance like if it's paying for
healthcare paying for that kid's future
I can't weigh in on that you know that
might be the right thing to do but
sometimes I see these mommy influencers
Duncan Trussell and I were actually
talking about this on his podcast like
that that you know because I'm looking
at Tik Tok to learn how to parent
because that's you know probably get a
lot of tips it's actually great yeah
there's a lot of really goodu you know
why I think they want to ban Tik Tok
because we all
communicate like there's a lot of good
stuff on there and can I tell you
something there's great stuff on there
and there's a big contingent of look how
Bill Gates just bought
Bragg's uh apple cider vinegar and he's
putting his weird GMO appe peal apples
in these natural tinctures and why does
he own half of the that's good to know
too yeah I know I'm saying like people
are sharing getting information on there
my my Tik Tok algorithm is all like
Comics I'm jealous of
and and like this is what's in your food
and this is the corporation that just
bought this natural brand that you think
was natural and it's not natural anymore
and it actually has endocrine disruptors
in it wow yeah I'm sure I'm sure
raccoons and dogs no raccoons but no
cosplayers maybe lots
of what's cosplay I don't even really
know what that is Pat y Pat is that when
you dress up as a a animal and have sexs
it's well you went
deep it's pretty much what our world is
becoming no one wants to ever be normal
anymore so it's like it's just think of
furry and and fuzzies I thought it was
that's like comic when you dress as a
video game character ComiCon people are
not dressing like that regularly you
know what I'm saying so it's like it's
cosplaying like characters and stuff
like Zelda but like sexy you know what
I'm saying got it got it got it but they
do it with so many in their videos yeah
and that's like a way to like is that
like the Renaissance Fair like how
people dress up for the Renaissance Fair
way it's gone way past that okay but
it's yeah there's a lot of that I mean I
was just joking but it is a big thing
okay I see it because I go to I mix up
furries and cos like I don't know like
we're Way Beyond okay but um I go to
these Tik Tok mom influencers and like
this is the best way to get your baby to
take a bath like actually do this and
actually put a sock on its head or hold
it whatever it is like these little
hacks
and sometimes you'll see these really
successful ones and you know they'll
have 80,000 views but they'll be like
3,000
downloads so that means it's not getting
good views no it means someone's
downloading videos of these kids oh oh
what's up with the downloads that's
terrible so I just think Tik Tok should
have a set you can't download videos of
I mean I guess you could always screen
record I guess there's always a way to
do it but I'm like did these mother
trick us into making our own child like
how oh God you know that's that's what
Spooks
me I don't even oh I don't even think
like that yeah well do I just saw
because I was like sending it to my mom
friends and I was like I guess on Tik
Tok you can see download like you can
download a Tik Tok and I was just like
why I mean look that's something you
know you hear about I don't know enough
about it but these videos that they make
on these channels sometimes are real
weird and there's a popular for like
kids videos I like the episode of your
podcast where you talk to the people
that were talking about um let's call it
wisney because every every time I talk
about wisney and the castles being dicks
the gets taken down I don't get in
trouble takes it down it's well I had a
and I was just joking about you know are
the Disney castles made of dicks like
you know they have I think what happened
was there was just underpaid animators
that were like you and just made in the
cartoons are the actual castles on coup
so there's the Disney Castle has one
that looks like a dick there's one of
Mickey and Minnie and her shoulder like
puff looks like a dick going into his
mouth I mean it's kind of like I never
noticed it before someone pointed it out
like and The Lion King the Lion's nose
kind of looks like a woman's butt like
well you've gone down oh yeah oh yeah I
appreciate this this is good cuzz you
were not like this you I've always been
like this really yes I I feel like
you're opening up now really good let's
go back there but I want to go back to
what you're saying Hollywood's market
share is getting smaller and smaller and
smaller and the loudest influence is the
tiniest margin okay like understand what
does Hollywood even mean like that's not
even a word understand Tim Allen's
normal right you understand I'm normal
Rob Schneider normal you know what I'm
saying like we're all been on sets
together with people that are super
liberal and we all got along until I
guess a couple years ago everybody had
to pick a side like yeah it's crazy fors
for dorks yeah so it's like so Hollywood
the woke left or whatever the want to
call it is getting so marginalized that
it's turning off everyone you know it
you go to Indianapolis people don't
think like this Yes But the irony is
woke left is what they think the
conservative alt-right is it's pure
censorship it's you don't have autonomy
over your body you have to get
vaccinated to come in here you're not
allowed to say this you're not allowed
to say this and we don't believe in free
speech unless you agree with me so like
that's they're just have lost mind so
everything they rail against yeah it is
it's you're totally right no I mean I I
I think that coming out to Hollywood I
didn't think about it like because I
started I just want to do standup and in
standup I remember going don't be
political just be funny actually Byron
Allen who you and I work with in the
first couple years that I was doing
standup he sat down with me and gave me
incredible advice he's like don't try to
be everything to everybody he's like if
you are if you know a lot about politics
do that be Bill Maher if you know if you
don't you know know a lot about being a
Democrat talk about that I was like I
don't know enough about that and I was
like I really just like talking about
sex and relationships he's like what's
your favorite show it's like Sex in the
City he's like be the Sex in the City of
standup only talk about one thing so
everyone knows what your store sells
like he put it in the most genius
business way and then I went great so I
was like I'm not going to think about
politics I'm not going to talk about
politics it's not my place whatever and
then when I worked on the Rosanne reboot
MH that's when I got this hit of like
everyone in Hollywood was mad at me like
how could you work with someone that
voted for trump it was like huh like I
was I got so much shit so much trouble
and then people that I worked with
because I do Joe Rogan's show and
Rogan's a friend of mine would be like
oh because you're a conservative
comedian and I got I lost a lot of f
like during the pandemic Comics like and
people in Hollywood dm'd me and they
would be like I can't believe that
you're going on The Joe Rogan show like
I'm like huh I can't believe you're
working with Roseanne she voted for
Trump I'm like what the like have you
really decided that someone shouldn't
exist because they didn't vote the way
that you voted like you know so I that
was I guess when that happened you lost
a lot of people really yeah but but
gained cooler people 100% were you
really cool with them or was it
Hollywood it was definitely people I was
in writer room with people I had hired
people that I had worked with people do
you know what I think that is I quate
that to insecurity on their part they
want to look okay with their friend
Circle and we have to be able to be okay
with being alone and by the way these
aren't just people that were like behind
my back like oh Whitney worked with
Roseanne she's you know uh like
supporting a trump supporter or which by
the way Ran's braver than all of us
which by the way that's true but by the
way the whole point
hey the whole point of doing Roseanne
was Jackie voted One Way Rosanne voted
another way and we were going to make
the show about how these families are
being torn apart like we're not taking
sides brilliant take but we're not
taking sides and if Roseanne hadn't have
voted for Trump that wouldn't have been
it wouldn't have been this amazing
ability to explore this so it would have
been a exactly what's going on in
America a fictionalized version based on
why so why didn't it and I said it in
like a vulture interview which I guess
vulture New York Times or New York Post
or something like it's like the most
liberal of all liberal even though now
the New York Times it's like they hire
journalists that tweet supporting Hitler
it's like what the happening um but uh
basically I said I would like to explore
why people thought Trump was a good idea
let's make that show let's make the show
showing Roseanne's philosophy which was
just because we're poor doesn't mean
we're stupid and let's figure out why
they thought Trump was such a good idea
let's make make that show great idea and
then everyone you know but so but it's
one thing to like be mad at me behind
the scenes or talk shit about me or
gossip but like to need to send me a
message or text going like hey I just
want you to know I'm unfollowing you
because you're working with Roseanne or
I'm unfollowing you because you went on
The Joe Rogan show I'm like
cool you seem cool
that's sick it's insane I know it but
there's the can we're all going to be
canceled yeah but the the people that
are canceling cancel you're not taking
risks and you probably shouldn't be a
comic yeah like every we're all either
going to end up on Disney Plus or all
have a patreon our only
fans that's it like there's no in
between like the Hollywood is getting
gobbled up you know and it's going to be
less and less I just hope Saudi Arabia
buys me that's that's my only hope at
this point there's a shot they're buying
a lot they buy golf they're going to try
to buy WWE they're buying tennis I'm
available add me to cart wow I'll D I'll
dye my hair blonde and lose 600 lbs like
whatever you need me to do I need the
car here wa a minute I'm in let's go
please buy me I don't she did that I
didn't you did that right now in this no
I was just I was
chilly gifting to friends and family
with young children or a new baby is a
nightmare cuz let's be honest most toys
could kill a
baby every toy someone's given me I'm
like you know I'm not going to let that
anywhere near my child right but I am
close to having a kiddo I'm already
getting stressed about making sure that
I documenting it all properly I'm trying
to make these photo folders of you know
these sonograms and everyone is I don't
know everything's just falling through
the cracks you know hash mom brain but
everyone keeps telling me the most
important thing to have and the best
gift you can get is having your photos
of your baby all in one place organized
you're look everyone's like you're going
to have want these photos later you're
going to have to take a lot of photos
the baby's going to grow so fast I don't
know I just I'm trying to be organized
about it it's just not working I because
my phone the phone being a camera makes
no sense I have my work stuff I can't
figure out what folders are shared
people invite me to folders when they
take pictures I also I will not be
sharing photos of my child on social
media okay unless someone wants to pay
me to do so in which case I absolutely
will please reach out to United talent
agency look I've Been Told by all of my
parent friends that the best thing to
give any new parent that will bring them
constant Joy is the sky light it's a
touchscreen photo frame that you can
send photos straight from your phone and
they appear in seconds you can even
preload photos before the Box is open so
when it's unwrapped and plugged in your
most Treasured Memories will appear this
is the perfect gift for literally
everyone so Pat and I set it up right I
got to be honest when I see something
like this I'm like it's a
cord there's a cord involved I don't
know Pat I don't know Pat there's a wire
there's I'm like kind of not taking on
new cords at the moment but this was so
worth it do you see okay so all you do
is email the photos and they go straight
here you're not trying to parot you're
not trying to you don't have to get on
Bluetooth there's no rigar roll like
this is so genius you just make an email
every photo that someone emails will
show up look how cute this is okay ah
and it just like switches that's a
little sonogram picture and then it's
just going to alternate over and over
again so now what RFK who last week made
fun of the fact that I have no photos in
my home now what now I have the
Skylight okay Skylight is the best
digital frame for grandparents hands
down because they still know how to you
can have an AOL
address it's intuitive easy to use for
new parents Skylight frame it's like a
baby book or a time capsule that will
save and beautifully display each and
every special moment for your spouse
perfect for commemorating special event
like a a wedding a honeymoon or reliving
just your favorite memories together of
you guys walking along the beach or
whatever people in love do I still don't
know it's a great group gift invite
multiple friends and family members to
share photos all in the same frame
literally takes less than 60 seconds to
set up I just watched it happen Okay
when a new photo is sent tap the heart
button to say thank you to the sender
there's also a larger 15inch frame that
can be wall mounted there's new color
options I I like the white one you know
that I'm going to cover it with laby
stickers any minute now but they also
have black silver limited edition poppy
which is like an orangey red they have
gold Skylight is so confident that you
will love it they are offering a free
120 day return as a special limited time
offer for our listeners get $15 off your
purchase of a skylight frame when you go
to skylightframe.com
Whitney to get $15 off your purchase of
a skylight frame just go to
skylightframe.com
Whitney I know what you're getting for
Christmas Pat you're gonna spell
Skylight
frame are you gonna do it that would
make my
year me getting through an ad no if you
if you could spell Skylight frame I'm
just looking at this s
s s k y l i g h d f r
m.com
slash
Whitney I've said what I need to
say like I just feel like I'm repeating
myself at this point if you guys are
still not using quip I just I don't want
to be near you I don't want to be near
your breath I don't want to be near your
bathroom like I kind of divide people at
this point between people who have quip
and people who
don't like they have this water floss
okay so here's the thing that they don't
tell you when you get pregnant um that
your gums just start bleeding when you
brush your teeth all the time you just
have like a constant Stigmata type of
thing it's pretty cool thank God quip
now makes a water flosser which hits all
the right spots with gentle or deep
clean pressure at the touch of a button
it has an extra wide lid that fits right
under the faucet fills up in seconds
it's cordless okay cordless rechargeable
battery lasts up to eight weeks so
you're not dealing with any bulky
charging docks or Tangled cords that you
will inevitably get wrapped up in and
perish on okay this thing blasts away up
to 99% of plaque and popcorn and gum
whatever whatever you're up to from
treated areas with Precision thanks to
the
360° rotating magnetic floss tip that
snaps into place look at this ma'am I'm
obsessed with quick toothbrushes you
already know this they're sexy they're
sensual look at this they make it so
your bathroom doesn't look like a dollar
store nightmare with stylish and
Affordable Electric brushes starting at
just
$25 you won't be paying through the
teeth for better oral health if you go
to getquip.com Whitney right now you're
going to get 20% off any electric
toothbrush mint and gum dispenser or
water flosser that's your 20% off any
electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser or water flosser at
getquip.com Whitney spelled get G tqip
p.com Whitney quip the good habits
company okay so I'm listening to your
podcast I'm obsessed with your brain
obsessed with How brave you are talking
about all this stuff I had Taran Manning
on the podcast recently and it went very
viral this one uh part that we were
talking about where I'm still not
totally sure what she was alluding to
and we still text about it but you know
she said she was offered the gold juice
did you see this clip I did okay I did
what do you think um I have no idea what
the gold juice is um I can imagine what
she's alluding to I here's what I think
here's my theories are a couple things
okay so drinking the gold juice is what
she said and she and she did say because
I was like is it adrenochrome is it I
don't think
adrenochrome I do think it is true and I
know this is true that there's
facials with baby I I don't know it's B
if it's baby forkin or if it's Bine
forkin but like stem cell facial is
something whether it's a scam or not I
think that's probably what started this
right MH what when you want to go down
I'll answer this okay okay so I my
guesses were ADR and of course because I
guessed adrenic chrum everyone's like
look at Wendy pretending she doesn't
know what adrenochrome is or that she
uses it or whatever so there's that
Scientology
Illuminati which maybe those are
[Music]
synonymous or some other Cults that I
don't know like bird song or U what's it
called fre song I
know that's like the church with like
Bieber and like the big but the guy got
canel
MH the gold juice so let me let me let
me try to give you a good detailed
answer here okay I don't know I mean I
have all ideas what she's alluding to I
I tell everyone this I've had a lot of
fun in this town you know what I'm
saying I've never seen
anything really weird I've seen a lot of
fun I've seen drugs I've seen sex but
I've never seen anything past that and I
so I was talking to Jack Osborne about
it it was like we go to the
Afterparty but we never went to the
after after party yeah we don't get
invited because we're loudmouths and
we're snitches and there are people that
they they say they caness you out and
see how far you would go we would be the
worst person to approach about the gold
juice yes because we would Yap about it
or do a joke about it yeah but someone
like Taran Manning who's in all these
movies and she you know said I come from
nothing and you know like she's an
easier person to but I don't know exact
there's a lot of rumors and I'm not but
I don't know exactly what the gold juice
is but I can imagine what she's alluding
to but I've never seen anything what are
you
imagining
well I mean well you could start so
simple as just a golden shower I mean
you could go there what does that mean
if I you let me or you could like do
this to get the gold it could be an ug
so let me pee on or no let me do this
and you'll get the secret juice that
will keep your career going or whatever
gold juice juice Jesus don't say that
what is that what an Oscar is don't say
so wow so but um but here's what here's
what I want to tell you so let's just go
back I'm not going to say adren Chrome
because that gets it could also be just
a metaphor for the most powerful people
metaph know that you are willing to be
passed around or it could be a metaphor
and then all the most powerful agents
and producers go like she drank the gold
juice she's in with us let's give her
the the most jobs let's give her let's
make her a star and she owes us it could
be a metaphor but I have to comment on
something after that to remind me so is
that I was successful in spite of all
this and I talk about it on my pod I was
never placed I auditioned hard yeah me
too I went in I fucking thought I would
make funny choices
I never sucked one dick you know what
I'm saying and I'm not saying a lot of
people haven't and they maybe a lot of
people haven't and that's okay if it's
mutual fucking but I don't really think
that sexual favors Works they don't I
think that I think that if you if you
like sleep with the director or
something like oh I got what I wanted
out of her why would they hire you then
I mean this was by the way before the
leverage of I just sucked your dick and
I can tweet about it if you don't hire
me like you can negotiate now but like
are like
dud give this girl a line no one's going
to hire their girlfriend or the person
they're sleeping with it's going to make
them look bad exactly they're like oh
literally because they go what did she
suck your dick you know what I'm saying
I and I also I mean look if if it worked
I would do it it's way easier than
driving a van eyes and learning seven
pages aside you know what I mean and
like it just it doesn't like but it
doesn't but but listen there are people
on both sides and in the male and female
gender that have maneuvered that system
in a consensual way that I've been very
list I've heard about like big producers
and the lead actress the lead actress
who already got there because she was
talented and beautiful and and had an
ungodly alien like you don't become the
star of huge Oscar winning movies be
because you suck with but they go once
you're here if you give me these sexual
favors you can come into the editing
room and I'll help you win an Oscar I've
heard this too and pull out all the
stops yeah like I I definitely heard
you'll be on the cover of Vogue You be
on the cover of this it like helps once
you're already at a certain super high
level yeah and I don't want to name a
name but there's I think she said it but
it's not for me to say she didn't but
there's a very big
leg say it there's a very big legendary
star that she was already on her way and
that kind of happened I think and then
she became the star that she was going
to be anyway but it just kind of like
makes it easier and gives you a more
power exactly in a weird way cuz I just
go like oh you have so much power over
me if I have this little power over you
why not take it and by the way what
everyone I just had this earlier on a
radio show people in hollyw hook up on
sets it's very there's a lot of
consensual stuff that people conflate
with other stuff now I don't I can't
hook up with a man wearing makeup but
okay everyone's like do you hook up with
the actors you work with I'm like
they're wearing mascara no you never
have no I have one time one time it was
a it was a pilot though it was a pilot
oh
but we we dated like for real for like
six months okay got you I didn't drink
the gold juice so it didn't get picked
up no gold juice so wait going back to
what she was saying could be an illusion
of many things or a metaphor but what
I'm going to say is this and I adren
Chrome would you say that you're going
to get a lot of people so here's what I
want to say is that I don't understand
how people think that's totally a crazy
thought because ADR Chrome yes because
I'm going to tell you
why the little the old old mouse young
Mouse experiment you can look that up
okay that's just an an little mouse was
sold was sewed on the back of an old
mouse and the older Mouse became more
youthful okay um there was a project
with Peter theal where they wanted to do
what they call blood packing you can
look this up it was a business and Peter
theal was like blood young blood has I
mean am I saying does it have to be baby
no it wasn't any of that it was just
like like your blood type and it was
like if you have youthful blood running
through your veins you become more
energized this is this was a company
that they were going to start the same
thing this guy Brian Johnson you do the
well hold on let me so you do the
vampire facial that's all that but let's
even go simpler but vampire facial I've
done that that's your own blood spun
with your own PRP yes okay but let's
just go simpler okay so there's those
things here's the simple okay I did I
worked in Africa multiple times in terms
of did some movies okay one of the
biggest things and this is going to get
your attention is the stealing of a
rhinoceros horn it's brutal it's it's
disgusting and not they don't just chop
it off they cut it and they dig in and
they feel it and a lot of them times
they die okay it's by poachers and to
get it down out of there is a big deal
and it's like
$200,000 and there's people taking money
on each part of the process of the
transaction what happens to that horn
what I'm told by multiple people is they
grind that
down and they put it in pills and they
sell it to very high-end people so
people would take this barbaric act and
use it so what I'm trying to say is it's
made of keratin Rhino horn made of
keratin so what I'm telling you is and
there was a whole thing of people
protecting it and they would shoot at
the poachers and there's other people so
if that happens on that basic level
where you can scientifically prove it
and if you look at the old mouse and the
young Mouse and you look at the blood
company you can look it up there has to
be and then also I mean what the Chinese
do with Bears and the gall Bladers
that's another thing too um also your
Teemu account is is closed my what now
Teemu what's teu teu is like Alibaba but
a little cheaper this is I think another
um because I want to talk about that
billionaire that I just brought up he's
a guy is that the guy that's going some
self he well he recruited his
17-year-old son recruited his penis is
recruited wait he's 49 and he said his
penis is 30 he recruited his 17-year-old
son Talmage and his seven-year-old
Father Richard to join him in the
world's first multi-generational plasma
exchange so he takes blood from his own
son and puts it in his body and how's it
going how I think he looks awful I mean
he just looks spooky he looks just like
a um like a claymation person is this
the guy that's does everything to make
himself seem younger or is it the same
guy or different guy um that's I mean
that's most men in La Brian Johnson is
his name have you seen him no he was a
nocal guy look what he looks like he's a
tech guy yeah I mean is that does does
that look good to you I think that's the
same guy but he cut his hair uh he looks
a little bit like an Android but he does
have have good skin yeah he's taking
blood from his own son wow to try to be
younger so there's that but it's not
baby blood per se but also I think
another um what's the word um piece of
information that kind of goes into this
is that a lot of vaccines were made by
growing the vaccine viruses in human
fetal cells so they took boarded fetal
cells I think this was in the
70s and they originated with fetal cells
so what's going on with aborted fetal
cells and that and there's a little bit
of conspiracy theory I'm deep on H Chan
at this point where when babies get put
up for adoption you know where they
really going that whole thing have you
dug into that uh that's definitely been
yeah there's definitely there's a lot
there's smoke but there's a lot of smoke
with this stuff and there's a whole
smoke with listen in fact you talked
about me on Rogan mhm and you said that
I did some abortion movie and you didn't
say anything disparaging oh this was the
one uh yes but I it came out two years
ago and it was made by a guy and it was
was was it made by um um Ben Shapiro
company no it was made by a guy Nick
lobe okay and look at he there's a lot
of stuff I read in doing this movie
people like why' you do this movie
didn't know about this movie listen it
was just a great role okay I didn't know
all the politics it and I got a ton of
shit every like the vulture and all of
these people and you talked about it you
said yeah Jamie got a lot of doing this
movie and what it is is that I learned a
lot about Margaret Sanger I learned a
lot about Eugenics I learned a lot about
Planned Parenthood do I know where the
truth is no but I there was a lot of
different things I saw I read that
weren't exactly in mainstream media I
think here's what I here's what we do
know
there's evil out there yes and within
something that might not even be a con
or a scam or a
horrible thing there's going to be a
horrible people are going to do horrible
things and I feel like in the last like
I don't know 10 15 years we've had the
Internet it's just we know horrible
people do horrible things so it becomes
less and less
unbelievable that someone would do
something Despicable for money yes and
it's not like the parenthood's evil or
the government's evil there are going to
be evil people in every organization
full stop and I think that that's where
what drives our brains kind of nuts yes
and you're saying is you can't commit
fully to one team and there's new there
evil people on the left there's evil
people on the right there's evil people
in the middle there's just evil it's not
men versus women or trans versus men or
left versus right it's good versus evil
you know what I mean and I think we tend
to go like but the left is evil the
right is evil it's like no there's good
people within both and there's evil
people and we're all just trying to find
them yeah like someone like I always say
Ben Glee because I love and evil people
like to lurk in good causes yeah because
that's the best place to hide I wanted
to comment on that but like someone like
Ben Glee is politics are very different
than mine but I love him he's hilarious
and we like laugh and I tweet with him
text with him all the time but he's very
different than I am but so it's like
we've lost that ability to coexist now
here's what you just wanted to say
something like that with evil is that um
I always think about this as you get
older I did this whole story with Dr
Drew how a guy I was urinating I was in
the uh baseball team I was when do you
what age do you start saying urinating
instead of piss taking a piss well I
hate to be crass and people are
like there's a lot of people on pods now
go I'm taking a
shit I was peeing so you're you're
dripping that golden juice yeah and we
had a guy that come in and me and the
Pitcher were in the Stalls next to each
other or urals and the guy came in and
my pants were a little bit down cuz when
you're a younger kid you're like nine
and you pull your pants down and it's
like your butt exposes I don't know
that's how like we did it it's fun and
the guy walked out of the toilet out of
the blue and he goes good game boys and
he
goes good game boys we're going to win
and uh uh and he goes you got a fat
Fanny and he guy hit my ass and he goes
I'm
like I have a fan yes what's he talking
about and I didn't think anything of it
until I did Dr Drew show and he's like
it took me till I was about 47 to
realize that I think that guy tried to
touch me because but he was a volunteer
and now I think about that type of shit
he didn't because you were too fat
probably cuz I had a fat ass I was the
original POG someone was going to molest
you and they were like never mind
fat ass I don't even know how I would
get in there water ice ass so no but so
it's but like I don't think about that
now like I was I I was an alter boy and
I wasn't touched which you know I do the
whole thing like it made me feel like I
wasn't cute so I joined the Boy Scouts
that's pretty low so but you know so my
whole thing is just like there are when
you see these things with like
volunteers and people they if be careful
of the I was told this by multiple
people be careful of the foster care
system because they go in there they
want to do that but they it's not what
they're doing anyone that It's tricky
because there's so many heroic people
that sign up to work with kids you know
it's the best people in the world or the
worst people in the world there's just
like no in between if you're signing up
to work with kids yes it's like that guy
Jimmy Saville oh God you really gone
down this fucker took a turn guys it
available for birthday parties
small Keras this really when a famous
celebrity is visiting a children's
hospital four or five times a week oh
God and everyone's like he's such a hero
he's such and then like we were just
blindsided by the fact that he was
molesting him you were why was a
celebrity man not at Studio 54 or
whatever England's version whatever why
was he at a children's hospital 34 just
donate homie I want to talk to you about
evil though okay please do you find this
and I talked to my buddy Jack about it
is
that evil
is I see sex more than anywhere anywhere
I see sex more than I ever have in my
life and I see weird Saint what do you
mean like in porn you
mean well porn somebody had this great
phrase we're in a post porn world I
don't know if you said it meaning like
the don't you don't have to go and get
the tape and look through the weird ass
squiggly lines and try to see a tit like
yeah porn is available anywhere you want
are you just figuring this out no but
that's a new thing that's a new thing
okay 2007 you you everything was
buffering I mean this is we remember 15
years yeah but no it's it's hyper of
course no no no of course agree so and
it's insane yeah and you know I mean
it's crazy the amount of sex that's
everywhere to the point where I'm like
almost turned off it's like there's like
where is the I know a lot of that have
quit porn yeah a lot of guys because
they were like sex just wasn't enjoyable
anymore I was getting desensitized to it
like it just feels gr because there used
to be like a I'm gonna sneak in I'm
gonna get a Playboy I'm gonna or I'm GNA
watch this you know there was just a
little more of a Chase now it's like you
it just it bombards you at this point
anal is hello and what we've got and
what we've gotten to the fact that it's
like step brother step D you're just
like Jesus man is this how far we've had
to go guys yeah I know so so like that
is wild but like it's the decaying of a
society I don't want to sound like a
prude I'm not like a Christian or
whatever I'm just a normal person any
argument to be is there any statistic
that cheating goes down when porn
consumption goes up like where men just
cheat because you watch Mad Men and
you're like oh if this guy just had
PornHub maybe he could stay faithful to
his wife I don't
like is there any positive benefit to
porn besides the argument that girls are
able to show their boobs on only fans
for money and not go out in the streets
and do it dangerously or you know what I
mean like I'm trying to think of I'm not
trying to play Devil's Advocate I'm just
curious I mean look there's a whole
argument to what it was and what I mean
like there's a lot of smoke around
Playboy I went to the Mansion at least
10 times I never saw anything weird I
had had the greatest time the parties
they were fun amazing food my only
problem with the playy Mansion it was
chill it wasn't just I see the crazier
shit on Instagram of what people are
insinuating yeah yeah now my only my
biggest quam with Playboy Mansion is
Hugh Hefner buying Marilyn Mon Rose
grave so he could be buried on top of
her he did yeah oh he wanted to be face
down on oh my God are you kidding me is
that true not even a big Marilyn monrose
stand like I'm kind of like do how much
longer do I have to pretend she was
smart like can we like is this like why
do we why is Marilyn Monroe like I'm not
a feminist if I don't think her quotes
are brilliant
whatever wait I'm a hey Lamar Bitch
myself wait that just Twisted me up he
said that what that's weird that he did
that is that true yeah I mean he's
here's the thing we talk a lot about
sexism and racism and M we don't talk
enough about agism he's he just kind of
old he's just like a old probably that
was his hero he was like his super but
that's crazy yeah like in the is called
a mle and Playboy publisher Hugh Hefner
reportedly paid a private seller $75,000
for the crip next to the late actress
next next to okay but he said he wanted
to be buried on top of her okay but he
didn't no he didn't I guess he's next to
her yes they bought the tomb next to
Maryland's determined to pass eternity
with Playboy's first Playmates okay oh
nope Richard P I have brought this up on
the podcast before I I knew see I'm
always eventually right
Jamie Richard P sing who owned the Crypt
above Marilyn was even buried face down
so that he could stare at her in the
afterlife who so so Richard poner did
that wow that's normal creep that's a
creep yeah but he didn't do that bummer
okay wait let's go back so so and all I
want to say is because you went down all
the way you forgot to mention Satanism
Satanism so let me ask you I feel like
that's everywhere let me ask you about
Satanism you mean like the like the
symbolism of Satanism you think people
are intentionally putting it in porn
intentionally putting it in Super Bowl
shows to capture the minds of the youth
I believe that all of this stuff because
we talked about Tik Tock and there's a
lot of like sharing everything's peer to
peer so I trust my peer you you trust
Amazon reviews more than you trust
someone selling product correct so it's
peerto peer so you know we see all this
stuff and it just seems like yeah there
has to be some smoke there when you see
an artist who starts out fun and light
we're talking about Sam Smith just say
it well he's one of them an amazing
beautiful man yeah beautiful a voice of
an Angel MH the Hollywood business is
pretty there's there's Sinister stuff
going on but I think for the most part
it's a lot of really insecure people
that just want Daddy Daddy to love them
and that are you know definitely you
know narcissistic but for the most part
insecure didn't get laid in high school
are obsessed with just it's Revenge of
the Nerds it's a lot of the Nerds she's
spitting all facts folks okay so that's
Hollywood I'm sure there's Sinister
stuff going on at levels that you and I
we don't get invited to yeah thank God
we just don't okay and yeah thank god
um music is another level the music
business what I will say thank I I I am
not burning any Bridges because I am so
untalented are these Bridges you want to
cross no of course not okay they're
bridges that that Prince and Amy win
housee were pushed off of by the devil
so but when I first moved to LA I think
it was maybe in a couple years someone
invited me to a Grammy party what year I
I I can find out in a second because it
was the year that when Houston drowned
in a bathtub it was Clive Davis's I
might have went to that Grammy that year
go ahead uh I went to a part Clive
Davis's night before party so you went
to that that's the party we went to the
party MH she's still in the
bathtub they didn't cancel the party
she's upstairs and I remember being like
is she like why is this party even
happening like you we kind of found out
when we got there it was kind of before
just like constantly being on Twitter
and it was sort of like we're not
canceling this party what is this
business this is wild you know and you I
did recently um listen to this podcast
I'm going to find what it is about how
the CIA killed Jimmy Hendrick and
because he wanted to get sober and the
conspiracies about uh Kurt Cobain trying
to get sober and trying to keep him
hooked on drugs and the glorification of
using drugs so that more people in
America would keep using drugs and keep
them dumb keep them dumb keep them
sedated people on drugs don't vote that
kind of thing and then Elvis having a
double and him having died much soon I'm
kind of I'm a little bit even if it's
just for entertainment I'm into Double's
territory right now really I just don't
think I don't know if that's Britney
Spears on her Instagram I'm sorry I
don't know I don't know dude yeah I
don't know that's a really good point
here's what I'll say this is going to
sound very paranoid and I'm doing it
half for for sort ofic value way I just
follow you now I'm not trying to make a
point I'm going to keep going with you
I'm hanging on I'm just saying are you
telling me this girl who was a
visionaire even if you're look why is
she wearing the same peasant top from BB
in every why is she wearing boots from
Aldo like she's still there was a closet
full of Versace somewhere yeah she
doesn't all of a sudden only have
clothes from Dillards like what she's
Britney Spears her teeth are now like
suddenly far apart mhm you know what I
mean so you're saying it's a double a
clone or what I'm not saying it's a d i
I don't know maybe there's the gold
juice goes sideways after a while
because I have also seen there's some
celebrities that did a lot of HGH and
then if you do human growth
hormone what if that's the gold juice no
that's something everyone can get um not
everyone but you go on HGH and then if
you stop your appearance all of a sudden
gets a little bit
crazy did she ever tell you what the
gold juice meant no in the clip she said
cuz I was like you didn't go tell it
well I now I text with her and I'm like
everybody's asking what is the gold
juice here's the thing I don't want her
to like get murdered or something if
it's something that is above my pay
grade cuz I feel like she came on the
podcast this is Taran Manning like yeah
she was very brave I feel very grateful
that she came on she very brave she's
very brave I cut a couple things that I
you know when she was talking about
Crossroads and work with Britney Spears
and stuff like I didn't I don't want her
to get any more so I didn't want to pess
press to too hard but she said like it's
a metaphor you see what I'm saying and I
feel like she was
I feel like if she wanted to say more
she would have okay let me ask you this
for a second she just said something
about do you think there's doubles do
you think like there's doubles because
look at Biden he does not look anything
like he did 10 years ago you think
Biden's a double no he has a huge nose
he has earlobes are different I'm not
crazy you could there's a difference
between getting surgery he's totally did
he get a nose job well here's what I'll
say heads of state having doubles get
ear job that is
a talk to me did he drink did he drink
the the silver juice silver juice I mean
but here's what I'll say I think he's
got a chip for people who think Jamie
might sound crazy Vladimir Putin
absolutely they're with me I love how
she me she's on 16 Chan she's like Len
there's aliens we're taking the blood of
alien insects but listen Jamie just calm
down on a double of the president Little
Mermaid Little Mermaid's head is a giant
dick yes I know but I'm piece of shit no
just say I'm trying to agree with you
and add context which is heads of state
having doubles is pretty common Vladimir
Putin absolutely has doubles that have
had plastic surgery to look like him
their ears are in different places if
you look at Vladimir so then that just
needs to be told Poland uh uh the
president of Poland his private plane
was downed I Believe by Vladimir Putin
and they subbed his twin brother in for
like a couple years really remember that
movie Dave with Kevin CL so doubles in
politics like it's not something that we
think would happen in America but I'm
sure there was a point that they didn't
think would happen to Russia are you're
in double territory are you in Clone
territory okay clone I have let's just
say this so everyone understand yet okay
well let me just say something really
simple Biden clone Barbara strand clone
her dogs yes but they're very wonky but
bar but she did it so did Diane von
fenberg okay there you go so dvf and
Barbara this is just a known fact that
these are
dogs what's what are you talking about
I'm not saying he is a clone but I'm
saying it's not that weird I mean like
to think for a second I thought that
weird painting was a dog Pig and I'm
like oh God she's doing Maro right here
yeah look like a dog Pig but it's a
um no like so Jo bid does suddenly look
different kind of like how Jamie Fox
after his episode that did not look like
Jamie Fox I must say but he might have
been sick and Bloated and you know
look there's smoke with this
stuff this is a lot different this is a
lot different than you you talking about
your horse farm you're like yeah I want
to talk about the traffic so do you
think so okay so you think that Biden
has a clone or a like impersonator like
double I know
nothing but I definitely think he looks
different let's start there he looks way
different than he did he's been dead for
seven years yeah they it is a weekend at
BIR they are carrying his corpse around
but is it his corpse they're carrying
around so he doesn't look anything like
he used to look and there's a difference
between Botox a snip he look this and
I'm a I'm a fan so don't take this the
wrong way Kardashians if you there's a
picture of Kylie how she looks now and
how she used to look and you know she
had some up you know upgrades and that's
totally fine um but he looks way
different compared to his old than Kylie
looks to her old okay and she's very
vocal about what she's done yeah so he
looks way different um but what if like
there's also a chance that he like had a
stroke or something and and your ears
all of a sudden don't connect do strokes
make your skin disconnect but do strokes
give you a smaller nose help me help you
um do strokes make you shake hands with
ghosts when they speech put it there
cash put like come on what do we where
are we at this what are you doing jump
all the way in baby the water's warm but
then let me ask you so you think you
think that if it's a clone clones are
off so is that part of the reason that
he's acting so weird because clones
don't listen there's a listen let's just
go he can't walk flight do you think
they would let a clone walk up the Air
Force One flighted stairs with no one
helping it yeah he like people he he
trips up whoever said that he does I
know but they're like who let the Clone
yeah who let the Clones out
but no here's what I'm going to say
surgery for sure possibly old man when
to look younger
clone um a mask a bad double a bad
double bad double that's the territory
I'm in right now but clone you're like
this Barbara
Stan it was her dog why can't it because
you know how that dogs are cloned you
have to put them in the womb and they
have to be born so that would by the
logic if dog cloning applies to human
cloning someone would have to give birth
to a baby bid and it would have to grow
up for the past 70 years so he was clone
that okay that's a very good point so he
would have to get cloned and then grow
and then grow you can't give birth to a
7-year-old I mean I got the Johnson to
Johnson so I
might we don't know but so that's the
thing so unless by cloning you just mean
someone got crazy plastic surgery and
here's what I'll say I'm going to say
something wild so
yes look at this the reason I'm into
this so I was in Portland that's a good
point with the age thing I have to think
that thank you I try I was in Port I've
given I was in Portland a while ago okay
makes Berkeley look like Orange County
that's how crazy Portland right now I
it's wild and so I was in Portland and I
was on stage taking a drink of water and
someone was like my friend looks like
you oh bitch and I was like
bitch that's a step it's like girl I
good all a sudden you putting yourself
up there and I was like all right come
up on stage no and when I tell
you I
mean I mean it is oh so she does you
think she does look like you yeah more
and more okay now yeah the first picture
she looked a little
off more and more like you so I've
looked into this apparently there's six
people on the planet that like look
almost exactly like you like it's just
like a for everyone odds for everyone
like thought so if I know that the de
State probably knows that and thank you
saying that there's a deep
State I just want to acknowledge your
truth yes my truth thank you I feel seen
and so I would imagine the same way we
talked about this earlier there's a
bunker that has been kept secret for for
so long the Green Brier which they you
know it was probably easier to keep
secrets to be fair in the' 60s 70s ' 80s
um up until the ' 90s but I'm sure
there's got to be some plan that's like
we got to get these doubles on a on Ice
we got to keep there's a couple people
that look like everyone let's just put
some feelers out did the double thing
I'm also pitching a great movie idea
yeah you are this is well cuz there's
replicants you ever see that movie no
but my favorite idea for movie right now
is that um cuz Vladimir Putin has a
bunch of doubles but there's all this
like um you know uh this gossip that he
might have cancer or he's going to die
soon or he's going to get assassinated
and you know hit the nuke button like if
you're his doubles are you like trying
to keep him alive because what happens
to the doubles when he dies like do they
all just get exterminated like they
don't get to exist because they all
these all these guys that got plastic
surgery to look exactly like him yes
just the idea that they're like is that
confirmed cuz I believe that yeah
they're like chicken soup do you want to
like they're trying to keep him alive
and like protect him and like it's just
such a funny idea to me you can't you
know you can't even say red pill anymore
do you know that yes you it's been
co-opted I guess doesn't red pill mean
that you've been red pilled that means
you're now conservative and used to be
something somebody said it's a bad
termal but to me somebody everyone say
they go they say we can't say this and
I'm like who the it's always they it's
it's always it's always someone with a
pronoun yo true so uh the Double okay
you're saying so much but I want to say
this is
that do did let's just keep it simple
have you have how many times youve been
to the Denver Airport how many times
you've been there recently speaking of
this this is think I would set foot in
the Denver Airport what am I insane what
are you talking about no I'm I'm
obsessed with the Denver Airport of
course so Denver airport look it up they
needed an extra2 billion to build it and
the government wrote the check no
questions asked they went two billion
over budget and just the simplest thing
of the S of all of the symbolisms in
there and if you know anything about
this what you read if it's true that you
have to say it to make it real and then
it's just a lot of there's the horse
with the red eyes there's the but here's
the thing there's a post-apocalyptic
paintings there's sculptures if at the
Denver Airport say the conspiracy
theories there's aliens there or that's
there's everything there whatever
everything why would you why wouldn't
you put the
post-apocalyptic signage and the horse
with the red eyes in the LAX Airport to
throw people off doesn't that feel a
little
clumsy or on the nose well I mean we're
a bigger Hub so I would think we would
be yeah yeah I mean that's a very good
point that's a very good point if I'm
the head of the Denver Airport is where
we're going to hide the aliens and the
adrenochrome factories for the
government keep making we're going to
make the Clones whatever we're doing
with
it why am I going to also make it this
obvious cuz we're talking about it right
now don't you think they'd cover it a
little bit
better uh yeah yeah my might have to
think about that yes and no because you
have to kind of put it out there there's
that thing they call karmic retribution
so you have to make it real to do it if
vampires the lore of vampires is you can
never vampire can never come in your
house unless you invite
them yeah CU because then again there's
also the thing where you go so they say
they're doing it yeah and then it's
there why they didn't pick La I have no
idea no I just mean if I'm going to put
the aliens in the adrenic Chrome
factories and the Clone factories in
Denver I'm going to put all the satanic
Insignia in Sacramento so people go oh
that it's in
Sacramento it's interesting that's what
I'm saying I don't know it's a little
sloppy to go we're going to put all the
satanic in the place where satanic
happening well now you're doing like a
middle manager conspiracy like where it
should be like you're doing like a
scheduling thing cuz like we now know
about the Denver Airport being shady
they did we we we think they do but
there's all these ads in the Denver
Airport saying you busted us or alien
it's funny or the Denver Airport's the
decoy and it's really in Pensacola 100%
that's the other thing is sometimes
these same I would go it's not going
down at the Denver Airport that's what
they want us to think because we found
out about it s so exactly so who knows
but some of the saan people I do
question but then other people I think
that are the most saan are the people
that probably look you know like
insurance salesman like they don't want
to be always always always always well
that's the and that's why when you go
like you know oh we we we um got off
topic about um uh Sam Smith like is the
Sam Smith thing and maybe it doesn't
matter the music business going we know
that satanic is going to get
controversy and we're just going to kind
of go hey we're going to renew your
contract if you do something buzzier and
we make you the devil and you have to do
all this shit you know what I mean it's
like but why is the devil such a
prominent theme are they really my point
is are they really satanic or are they
dressing as satanic to get attention and
the real satanic people are the ones in
Brook's brothers and yeah you that I
agree with that I agree with like the
cleancut people could proba the real
Saint in this but I'm not saying there's
not a couple in these other like that
are looking like they're just
appropriating it to get controversy and
it worked you know yeah people are like
oh Sam Smith has a new album out but
it's kind of it's a hack move yeah
that's it's a hack it's like a dating
joke you know what I mean like yeah
totally totally it's humping the stool
it's a com right like it's like so
but let me just say this music is a
great place they always talk about with
all the stuff lives do you know that the
frequency of Music changed from
megahertz and that's the anatomy of a
hit that can kind of almost hypnotize it
how many times you hum a song or sing a
song over and over again because it says
it's this meah Heartz and like something
in
1948 it was changed and it literally
hooks Us in and it's the anatomy of a
hit so the idea is like you're getting
hypnotized by it kind of so if you look
at certain concerts this is a whole
thing I did pod people got mad about it
really yeah because they say that like
these things are big ass some of them
not all of them are big ass ceremonies
and you're kind of like concerts
basically yeah and it kind of makes
sense because we do comedy and you play
2,000 people we're not doing that but
when people are with you you're all one
thing yeah you're it's like the Mind
meld I mean you're basically renting out
some you're mind sharing or essentially
thinking for someone else for the hour
you're or two hours you're there
hypnotizing someone
but side note when Dave gr was on the
podcast I think it was like literally
episode two he talked about the anatomy
of a hit like there's some machine
whether that's metaphorical or otherwise
that you put it through and it gets some
kind of a score to see how catchy it
will be based on neuroscience and you
know how the music industry sort of
works I the music industry from what I
understand changes every day okay I'll
give you a good example a long time ago
there was a website that was called I
think it was called hit song science
H and there were these mathematicians
that came up with a mathematical formula
to determine whether your song was going
to be a hit or not whoa so they would
assign it a formula based on its Tempo
and time and key and whatever um so so
your song would have like basically a
number right and then they would throw
it into their system and it would it
would come out the out almost look like
stars in the night sky so each song is
like a little star so you're looking at
this readout and there's like stars
everywhere but there's these clusters of
stars that almost look like little
galaxies and so those were um I think
they called them like hit hit clusters
or something if your song fell into one
of those clusters then more likely than
not it would become a hit wow the only
reason being is because it shared the
same formula as a lot of other songs so
what that means is when something
becomes
popular you wind up getting a lot of
stuff that sounds just like it coming
behind it
because because that's what's popular at
the moment so it could be a Tempo that's
the thing that drives me crazy about
popular music is that once someone gets
like a song that's got like a beat then
all of a sudden that's like if I have to
hear
the
for every song for the last three
yeah as a drummer I'm
like it's fucking it's like calming you
down I'm so fucking pissed off about
that beat no but it's like you know
there's there's just more out there than
that so I think what happens um when
something uh becomes um popular
popular uh I don't know if you consider
it relevant
but then everything sort of gravitates
towards that and basically that that
just determines or dictates or um you
know influences everything around it
just because the music industry they
just want to sell records they just want
your song on the radio they just want to
make money from publishing and they want
to do shit like that so um you know it's
the stuff that's kind of off the beaten
path that I get into um and I think that
those sort of things uh might be a
little more influenced
or inspired by um life rather than just
like an industry thing do you think that
because of that they're going the music
business is using this to program people
with certain messages 100% I definitely
believe that there's tons of salal
messages in music tons so do you think
that the people in the music business
are in collusion with like the CIA or
someone who's like we need to get this
message out
100% no no question
no question and then let me ask you a
question about that because I don't I
love Leed Zeppelin and if you really
listen to the lyrics lately there's a
lot of stuff in there and I love them I
mean and also they're
so what's the word prolific and elegant
I mean there's so many types of music
with Ze sorry I didn't mean to dis uh uh
cut you off and also I don't have I I
don't I can't really speak definitely
the CIA is involved with that with
movies too but I definitely think this
CIA is involved with when messages that
are going out they don't like the artist
might just overdose and die 100% you
know what I mean I don't know about the
other but I do know I do feel that too
many people when they start saying that
is
disruptive
overdose on friends of mine take all day
every day and they're fine who have
small platforms you don't have a lot of
vitamins see here do you why I don't
know just like
emergency saying Whitney Cummings so
someone comes in here and like take all
this vitamin C I don't know so do you
think that the CIA there's like someone
there whose job is to collude with
someone in the music business and be
like we need to discourage people from
voting we need to discourage people
from we need to get these certain
messages out all
right I think that definitely
people entertain mment whether was
created for one reason is now a huge
megaphone it's a programming device
priming is real yes predictive
programming is also real okay and so
if there's definitely why are some
artists just pushed to the top why push
p p push why are some actors pushed
pushed pushed push come on when I've
done a movie called Enemy of the State
with the n say I never knew what it was
this was a baby movie and it's still a
hit today it's still ahead of its time
and you know how many CIA people were on
that to make sure that real I can tell
you this I have heard from two
sources that there are definitely
meetings with I already know the CIA
says stuff about scripts like if it's a
military type of script what messaging
they want to put out like Pro America
the CIA or these people in power want to
put out these messaging through
different forms of entertainment that's
100% believable but here's my but this
is my question if if I'm like I'm going
to become a singer and then I go make a
hit they're not going to go we need to
sit when he comings down in this private
meeting well what if it goes sideways
right like what if I think it's like
they're already child stars we already
have like a hold on them and we like
slowly do it in a way that they don't
even know we're doing it and it probably
has to be musicians that other people
write songs for people that write their
own music probably aren't going to be
susceptible to this right isn't it I
it's a how much can you be co-opted
someone like Oliver Anthony they're not
going to sit him down and be like hey in
order to get this deal we have the CIA
needs you to say this there's got to be
like the manager because there's a
there's a uh I guess Jimmy Hendrick's
manager used to be in the CIA and he's
probably like here's the song you should
put out and here's the songwriter it's
probably through if I'm if I'm going to
pull off this conspiracy I'm going to go
we're going to pair this songwriter who
the CIA works with with this pop star
and give him this song and figure out a
way to get them to sing it without them
even knowing that they're passing on our
messages I mean look I think it could be
that I think it could be somebody who
gets songs big on Soundcloud and they
start blowing up and then when they get
within the system they're like this is
an asset that's already there so it's
like you can consider it an acquisition
and they're like we need to get this
person on our side I know but how are
you telling me that there's not one
person so like say would be Katy Perry
who would be like the CIA made me say
this thing like wouldn't someone have
snapped by now or do they just kill him
first what do you think Britney's doing
you think she's
snapping what do you think Kanye did you
think he
snapped damn we're saying so much but I
don't give a because we have to let I
want truth I don't know the answers to
these things so you think that when they
when they're about so when about to say
it they either put him into
conservatorship or the did you ever see
Black Mirror did you ever see the did
you ever see the Miley Cyrus episode
well here's what I'll say did you see
the Miley Cyrus episode oh I didn't see
the American version no you have to
watch it okay watch that and then go
back to what we're talking about okay if
you don't think that there's big ass pop
stars in different forms of
entertainment that completely are
controlled uhuh come on did you watch
the idol no I didn't watch all of it it
will speak to you yeah it's really good
but it's also really true like making a
deal with the devil kind of thing but I
guess to me I just
wonder about is it is it a meeting you
have I don't think it's like that
cordial of like hello Whitney here's the
contract signning I think it's a slowly
build and I think there's a lot of
people that have a loud platform and
they here's my only question and I know
nothing I'm just saying this you see
people one way okay I did The Warp Tour
Believe It or Not Whitney I was a rapper
um I know my album you didn't get it I
can help you it's sptify and there was a
time during the Warped Tour that me and
my boy were playing the side L stage and
Katie Perry was like three stages over
doing Christian music sweetest pie now
listen now she wears pies on her tits oh
yeah I think you're right you're
definitely right and so what I'm trying
to tell you is is that I'm a big I love
Katy Perry music I think she's awesome
she's beautiful all this stuff was there
an image change sure but do you ever see
people sometimes where they're one way
and then you look at them and they're
like this they drank the gold juice what
does that mean they're not there they're
not there do you ever see that where
people are not there
like listen you so what do you think it
is I think it's a mix of many things
Ultra is real that's 100% that's 100%
real yeah yeah yeah but you're saying
that it's still happening or it happened
back when it uh in the original
experiments of MK Ultra I think that
happens because continually still 100%
100%
100% is that the gold juice it could be
text right now text her but like to me
people
are you see them one way that's what I'm
saying Sam Smith is not the same boy
that came into our business and I listen
again I know a chicking money corrupts
people too though 100% And also Fame
gets you crazy I mean I'm not Bieber but
I have my own Fame and I understand what
I deal with so I can't imagine being in
the rarest of air where you cannot go
anywhere on the because there might be
two things that happen like we're very
lucky that we get to be Comedians and
like hold on Taran Manning I wrote uh
could gold juice be MK Ultra she said no
and then she said something else I don't
want to read out loud um okay she just
wrote that happens daily to us all she's
not wrong she's not wrong but I think we
got known I don't know calling myself
famous it just feels weird but um you're
famous you're an entity you can go and
Trader Joe's and people recognize you
right okay but I think you and I because
we're also Comics like we're not removed
from society we actually because we're
famous we're closer into society than we
ever would have been before so so if I
just you know worked in an office job
and was a pargal I would see a very tiny
sliver of society only people that had
money to sue people or I would just see
these like Rich assholes all the time or
whatever or if I just worked at Chipotle
I would but like we're Comics we get to
do meet and greets and like to people so
I'm more in touch I feel like with
people than I would have been I had a
different job but if you're like a Katie
Perry or someone who's not a
comic you're removed you're so far
removed I don't I can't imagine how
awful and lonely and spooky and
disheartening and you only have people
I've seen this around you that are uous
with you and want something from you I
mean I get that a little bit but we're
Comics we can feel it out it's mostly
Comics asking me to do their podcast
that's you know as predatory as it
usually gets um but like you're just
that's the real predating in Hollywood
gone dude I know totally you're just go
you're just like I would imagine that
would be so um would turn you into a
zombie the fact that you don't have any
real human beings around you okay I have
a comment on that yes and yes but no
because listen I've done when I did my
TV show I was doing movies I had a book
you're on a tour Fame can do a number on
you
like they say I think when someone's
gone yeah I think Lindsay said it great
she said Fame is not doesn't you don't
become that it just exacerbates who you
are where you you know if you love
goldfish to the snack you can buy
thousand tub of goldfish so it's like
what did I buy when I I always ate I
always eat really good because I didn't
have food when I was struggling so I eat
the best F and so that's my Splurge you
know if you like Coke you're going to
probably do a lot more coke and the best
Coke when you get famous well whatever
sneakers so it just amplifies Fame
amplifies who you are yes so that's one
thing touring traveling all that stuff
is another thing um yeah having enable I
call them enablers like cuz I have
people in my life that I think believe
in me but I try to cut off all the siop
Fant yeah and the difference between
someone who believes in you is like hey
how was my set you go it started good
you had a rough middle but then you
closed strong that's would you that a
real person that's a real person okay
but or someone if I was putting heroin
on my arm and every day I give him a
th000 tip and I was like how is my set
and they go you're amazing are you
kidding me you're better than anyone and
you're like yeah so don't cut off their
that's what I always tell people are the
differences that's different than what
we're talking about but you I know but
we're just jumping around and I but I do
think that I'm into it there are
people yeah I think I think this whole
business is a work now I actually don't
think I think I broke through it somehow
luckily I also do just in terms and you
did too but did you or is this a whole
scop to get me out
here
P this is a wild this shit is simulation
de but you know what I really and and
like just getting putting the conspiracy
hat on like of when big icons die when
you're like how do you how does Michael
Jackson die how does Prince die wait
hold on I don't even have a com I don't
even have a conspiracy on that his
cocktail was insane that they were
giving him I know but let me can I uh
like it was it was uh what's what's the
stuff you go under in a hospital what's
it called uh propal no but it's also I'm
anesthesia he taking he was taking Ania
this guy was giving him anesthesia and I
do think you know you can kind of on
some level in the music business I guess
I hear you can kind of get whatever you
want whenever you want I'm sure you can
but there's also these like shady
doctors where you're
like who how did this H this
I think about like Prince's doctor I'm
like that feels like a CIA doctor like I
we're in this business if I need to go
you know broke my shoulder snowboarding
Chelsea Handler gives me the best
shoulder guy do you know what I mean
like if you just are have access yeah so
if you're Prince and you're like you
know I need to they're going to send you
the best guy who's a licensed person
who's like you know what I don't want to
kill Prince I'm not participating in
this you know what I mean I it just I
don't know if you've seen some videos of
Prince talking about Chemtrails and MK
Ultra and like now it's kind of just
resurfacing a lot on Tik Tac I didn't
realize how mouthy he was about some of
this stuff I've been seeing this that PR
they're saying yeah Prince was vocal
about about the system about the about
the government putting chemicals in our
food and all this kind but I guess I
just look at the doctors and you're kind
of like I don't this doctor
probably what doctor wants to kill
Prince like this wasn't a Doctor Who had
any other celebrity patient like they
were they're just these like shady ass
doctors and it makes me go like oh maybe
the CIA has a couple doctors that they
figure out how to for sure you know the
I'll send you the I'm sure I I don't
know enough about Prince's passing I
know a little bit about Michaels but to
me it sounded like the way they framed
it was the cocktail he was taking was
like for people that literally are going
into auma yeah but how do you kill how
does Prince I mean Jimmy Hendricks
there's a conspiracy that it was murder
yeah okay I mean did he I don't know I
don't know so did Marilyn yeah Marilyn
that seems like she definitely was
drugged yeah it's just very and I think
this is she went in high Sur this is
what interests me especially with um
like just seeing what happened with
Taran Manning and Kanye as soon as
someone wants to go oh they're on drugs
oh they're crazy that's when you got to
start listening to what they're saying
honestly from how I know you and what I
know of you I'm loving that you're doing
this because because you don't you come
off as somebody that was much more like
would listen to what Hollywood says
because you didn't want to get not that
you didn't you had you're a very strong
independent funny woman all this but you
definitely are fucking pushing against
the grain in a big ass way and that's
beautiful I think thank thank you for
saying that I think for me I think yeah
a lot of people when they would say like
oh Whitney so Hollywood or something I
was you're not I was like that's you're
not I definitely
think I knew to like I don't know I
guess for the longest time I didn't have
a podcast first of all and it was like
I'm gonna say what I'm going to say in
my specials and that's the only time you
really have the microphone to talk about
stuff and you know um but this is a lot
different than I'm your girlfriend this
is a that's special yeah this is on you
are blossoming into your own thing of
whatever you want to talk about and
you're not scared that's what I'm saying
is you're not scared that rosean
probably me a little bit and it did
because you wanted to work within the
game and they were you're like yo I'm
not doing anything wrong and they're
like they try to kick you out of the
sandbox and you're like you man and this
is what really I think for me like
pissed me off in a way that I I kind of
you know I had the best time at gang
fest with Roseanne by the way oh amazing
go um and to me it was like I don't like
bullies mhm and I think the left has
become a bunch of fake
um benevolent bullies and the look I'm
you got to have somebody here super left
sorry you have to have somebody in here
who's super liberal super super I
have we didn't air it oh or like we had
to cut because it's just sometimes when
you're talking to someone who's super
left they're like well it's the guns and
you're like give me more and they're
like it's the guns and it's the guns and
you're like have you ever had to live in
a rural area in your life have you ever
lived in a house with a screen door that
bears come in like do have you ever
lived somewhere that's 2 hours from a
police station have you ever been to
Prague yeah like seriously these people
need to leave and Ceno like I exactly
like I'm just like it's there's and you
can't there's no conversation to be had
yeah they're just saying tweets
close-minded motherfuck that's what I
hate closed-minded mother area I'm crazy
cuz I'm open-minded I think the word
conspiracy theorist should be a slur
like you're theorist it should be that's
interesting and by the way we're
probably wrong about a lot of what we're
saying there's no way of knowing but I
think our thing is going like we're on
the right path we're sniffing down the
right path well why are we thinking like
this yeah aren't you a comedian isn't
your job isn't it in your DNA to go
something's off here something's off
something doesn't smell right so it's
like when you go like H kids child
trafficking and people are abusing
kids 80 years ago 100 in this country
child labor was legal in factories that
wasn't that long ago wow you know what I
mean that wasn't that long ago yeah at
all at all at all you know what I mean
so you're saying so are we going to look
back in 50 100 years and go remember
when we let
children get makeup put on them by
adults to dance in television shows in
pageants remember when babies were in
pageants how Wild that was like I think
it's like on comedians to always be like
so hypervigilant and it was probably
going to come off a little bit anoid to
go like what are we going to think in 50
years about this thing Dance Moms that
had eight
seasons we're all just fine with the I
think it's child abuse but I also it's
entertaining to watch these bitches are
Bonkers I don't know mhm the adults yes
yes yes and then okay I love you but I
want
to so that's I'm like I'm sure I'm wrong
about everything I'm saying but I'm just
like why do you do that to yourself
maybe throwing this out there
or maybe you're on with breadcrumbs all
we're saying is something's a little
weird it's like when the
woan virus was in the it came out and it
was near a woan lab of virology but we
weren't allowed to say it what is that
that was wild that's what we're saying
that was wild you know what I'm saying I
always say there's no like you always
want to be a comic no it's the last
house on the left it's right for a rusty
needle like no one like to get to where
we are it's like good even now there's a
lot of pain so it's like
no so yes you're right most people the
cognitive dissonance that term is very
true I drank your coffee I'm sorry okay
Jimmy Hendricks was Mur oh this guy
tappy right my tongue Brown tappy right
um I'm gonna you know I'm just all that
Laurel Canyon stuff is a whole other
thing with music and CIA and Jim Mar L
and all that all the government was
putting it out there to keep you know
tune in drop out well Jared Leto bought
the house with the tunnels underneath it
right very interesting and we're just
fine with that very interesting nothing
to see he dressed as a devil at the Met
Ball and he also just Heist he also just
climb the Empire State Building also
just has his own Island that his fans go
to for a festival every year I'm going
to make a joke but am I beautiful skin
beautiful skin gorgeous skin gorgeous
jar so beautiful when he's on screen
with the co that's a woman I'm always
looking at your he's beautiful more
beautiful than most women so nothing to
see nothing to see here guys you this is
comedy you have to do a special called
nothing to see here and it's just and
it's just you saying all this stuff
that's brilliant it is oh my God nothing
to see here volume one and it's just you
like Jared Leto nothing to
see
wow that's brilant for 60 minutes just
Denver Airport horse with red eyes
nothing to say nothing to literally
where do I need punch Lines no Sam Smith
wore a suit and a skinny tie now he's a
devil horns in high heels nothing to see
here
guys it's brilliant that's it I don't
need punchline the punch Line's reality
Joe Biden earlobe doesn't attach to head
all nothing to see here guys bag of
cocaine in the most secure part of the
White House nothing to see here guys no
one knows where it's from Joe Biden has
a new nose all of a sudden nothing to
see here
guys keep walking
keep keep walking keep walking oh my God
Bry Spears hasn't brushed her hair in
six years keep walking nothing to see
here guys all of a sudden she has a gap
in her teeth nothing to see here
I'm amazed this is it this is it cuz if
you just say the truth out loud it's a
it's a joke it's a joke like you know
there's nothing we can ever make funnier
than this it's like isn't it hard to do
comedy now because the world's funnier
and crazier Lane Maxwell still no flight
manifest yeah they took a picture of her
there's literally nothing to see they W
release it yes they literally took a
picture of her in in and out do you see
remember that no before she went down
and um how the mighty have fallen yeah
but yeah we've you know okay I'm gonna
say Trump's got six
indictments we don't have one name from
that list nothing Al she's still
alive nothing to see nothing to see here
guys Jeffrey Epstein the cameras work 24
hours is in a Cell the security guards
were off cameras were off nothing to see
guys Jesus
there's nothing to see cuz the cameras
were off
yes you should you should do this in the
whole special and it's just over black
cuz you're like sorry guys the cameras
were off the whole time that's just a
common
malfunction apparently by the way if if
comedians get cameras to work on their
standup specials we get cameras to work
these C work how can I see clips of
people doing a 5:00 show at the Improv
perfectly lit bits that they never tried
in the lab but they think it's Netflix
worthy but I can't see the Epstein cell
camera eight-year-olds are making
millions of dollars off Tik Tok they
know how to make cameras work yes yet
brilliant this is Jeffrey Epstein's
cameras just all none of them work 100%
those Panasonics just from Radio Shack
shut down everyone
is what's the chick that Annie Lio with
the camera now but no one no uh-uh
nothing to see here not a thing wow
that's it we just had it we we can
co-share this this is I love you word
Duo wow it's true I hope my tongue's not
too brown with my coffee um okay can we
put up Whitney Cummings and Dan Cummings
I love hate to break it to you is your
podcast you got a movie coming out with
Matt R and um yes
Matt the
hilarious um and beautiful Matt R
December second uh we're coming out on
some platforms we're also in 10 cities I
don't have them yet I know Philly and
Tamp is one and then our show so my
podcast and then our show me Jamie and I
do a show called funny you should ask
and that's coming in December 9th game
show that's on CBS now CBS 8:00 Saturday
it starts and if it does well you know
what I'm saying it's actually you and I
screw around so much on that show we we
laugh mostly because I didn't think it
was going to be on CBS so now I'm sort
of like Whitney is like can you believe
how much money we're making and like no
well CU sometimes you'll just do a show
where you're just like oh I'm just GNA
like do like yes well first of all it's
the funnest time you'll ever have on a
set let's we have the best time we laugh
there's
icons icons that we work with it's us
it's um it's John litz John litz Howe
Mandel Byron it's Jack K Adam Cora yes
Tiffany hadish yes I mean the list goes
on Sherry sheeper um uh us us it's kind
of just that's Billy gell that's right
um it's just amazing fluffy you know
Bobby Lee so it's just like it's just
amazing to be in the realm of all
different voices that have made a mark
and then I laugh all it's also you laugh
all day we do we laugh all day you laugh
all day it's actually very cool because
it's it's a lot of big Comics just doing
jokes that's it literally no politics no
bullshit Byron is our amazing leader who
keeps us you know he's like hey man just
make people laugh yeah that's all we're
doing and it's needed I'm I'm All About
exposing everything but it's also I do
know that people need a break sometimes
yeah and it's also not Holly I mean it's
Culver City we're not in Hollywood
anymore we're Culver City now we're West
behind pops
Bagels I love you Jamie thank you for
doing this this is amazing thank you for
having me you're the best you got to
come do mine I would love to I would
love to okay I love it let's go thank
you guys I end these very awkwardly
don't ride elephants
[Music]
goodbye
[Applause]
w